I'm in a journalist with a cause and I've been so active against
oppression against radical Islamism against the Muslim brotherhood
and against care,
which is the council on American Islamic relations
relations that are the,
I call them terrorists in suits because these are the front of the
Muslim brotherhood and care who groomed a land groomed,
Rashida and many others. And by the way, in 2020,
we have more care has been grooming more than 120,
uh, Rashida Han alike.
When did you move to the United States?
So I moved to the United States in 1993,
as soon as I moved. Um, I started working in the media,
my mother as well. Um,
and then I started, um, doing, uh, um,
us media and Arabic.
And it's so funny because I was the youngest one. Um,
well, you know, voiceover American and voice of America is a federal, uh,
federal, uh, entity.
So when I applied for it,
there were like 400 something and I just went and I did my,
uh, test whatever.
And then a week later I was because there was only
one opening and I got it.
So even I know I'm like really,
um, but the first day I was at the office,
all of them were so much older than I am.
And they looked at me. I was like, who is she?
But the first hour I went on air, everybody came and it's like,
now we can say welcome to VOA. And that was a wonderful,
wonderful experience. Don't forget. I came here, I speak English. Uh,
so I came to the us speaking English.
So it wasn't that hard for me to just be there.
Plus I love the culture. I love this country. And, uh,
it's home. It's this where my heart is.
But I don't understand.
I thought we were told all the time that America is an evil, racist,
patriarchal state that no dark skinned immigrant could come to and be treated
fairly. Especially if they come from the middle East to a place like Iraq,
something like that. Are you telling me,
are you telling me that's not true? And you,
if you'd love this country and work hard, you might be able to make it.
Is that what you're telling me.
Been here three decades? Uh,
it was very easy for me to move somewhere and live. If I didn't like it,
why would I stay here if I did it? Like it it's one of the most,
it's one of the greatest, it's the greatest country in the world.
And, um, yeah.
Is it shocking to you as someone that lived under what you lived under,
had to do everything that you just laid out to even get here?
When you hear all of this endless,
ridiculous craziness about how horrible America is,
is it just mind blowing to you?
It provokes me that first of all,
let's talk about Ilhan Omar, and that's, that's fine.
We were going to get there. There's a lot of Johan Omar stuff here.
Because I truly believe that when you
go to a new country and this country B becomes your
home, I mean, at least be,
be grateful that you, you have,
you live in a country that you have the right of
every single American. You're no different than anybody else.
You have the right and you have the duties and that's how you should, uh,
deal with it. Yet.
There are immigrants from different countries. I'm not saying from or from,
uh, that they come here and they don't integrate with the communities.
So they still live in small area that it's
basically, they brought everything from their country and they're not willing to
participate or willing to be part of the, uh,
of the community. And that's what I feel that, um,
organizations and, and, uh, should work on,
on these communities to build bridges, to make them feel,
um, integrated, um,
in schools and workplace and others.
I mean,
can you believe that someone who lives in for 20 years in a
country that can't even speak the language,
how.
You mean it's not racist to say that maybe you should speak language of the
country you live in, or at least try to.
I mean, this is ridiculous racist, no,
this is, this is the country. This is the language of this country.
You want to be a part of, of this country,
part of the communities you want to be, uh, uh, you want to provide,
uh, uh, you want to fulfill your duties. So you get your rights.
I mean, this is, come on. I mean, at least speak the language,
at least read a sign.
Okay. So we can link all of this to Ilhan.
But before we get specifically into her,
just tell me a little bit about what your general political philosophy is,
because now that you're running for Congress, obviously that's, it's,
it can't just be about I'm against Ilhan. Oh, we'll to that,
but just tell me a little bit about your own sort of political beliefs.
Uh, a question that I've been asked so many times thinking that
all immigrants and, um, they're,
they should be Democrats. I'm a conservative person. I have conservative,
uh, principles, um, since I came here. So,
um, being a journalist, I know exactly what these two,
uh, political parties are. Uh,
so it's easy for me. I mean,
to be conservative and to be Republican. And that's what I've been since,
since I, I came here, I truly believe that, uh,
decency should be back in our political arena and our
lives. Uh, we we've lost it.
We've lost it. And this is, this is so bad. I mean,
they hatred that we see now,
this was never the narrative in the United States. Yes,
we disagree, but we don't hate each other.
I don't hate somebody because he's a Democrat.
Maybe I would never marry a Democrat,
but that's what we fighting all the time.
But not as politician. Yeah.
Exactly. But you know what, uh,
it's sad that you see in 2020 that hatred a,
that, um,
the toxic narratives coming from the far
left, I wouldn't say coming from the Democrat in general, the,
the far left and the progressive that are trying to
destroy this country. People don't want this,
this country to be a socialist country.
People don't want to live in Cuba.
People don't want to live in Venezuela.
People don't want to live in these countries or even Russia for this matter.
So we have people that are appraising these other
countries. Um, I mean, if you praise it,
then you like it so much go be a Senator there.
Right. Well, that's what I always say. Nobody ever leaves to come here.
Nobody's leaving. We're not stopping people from leaving, but they,
they never leave. So was it seeing what was happening with the,
with the far left progressives and the socialist?
Is that really what drove you to get into politics?
Or was it specifically about Ilhan? And then we'll talk more about it.
Well,
being a journalist and I've been doing it for a long time and I do foreign
affairs and, um,
I cover the whole world and covering
Wars, uh, uh, conflict zones, human rights,
crisis, um, terrorist attacks all over the world,
especially in Europe. I've been there, done that.
I've so I know what kind of,
of outcome would come from a narrative like, like this,
the oppression B uh, the hatred, the antisemitism,
and I think, uh,
Alon Omar made the biggest mistake of her life.
It was right when she, uh,
got elected and she didn't wait for long to bring out
all the ugliness.
Yeah. Well, it was almost like day one.
She suddenly flipped on all of these things,
even though a lot of us could see it beforehand, obviously.
Yeah. But, um,
being there as a journalist and I'm, uh,
I'm very active. I'm an,
a journalist with a cause and I've been so active against oppression
against radical Islamism against the Muslim brotherhood and against
care, which is the council on American Islamic
relations that are the,
I call them terrorists in suits because these are the front of the
Muslim brotherhood and care who groomed a land groomed,
Rashida and many others. And by the way, in 2020,
we have more care has been grooming more than 120,
uh, Rashida L Han a lot.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.